paul feig uh the director who has made
like the heat and bridesmaids and spy
and like the best things ever in life he
is delivering none other than welcome to
flash which is your new series tell us
about it it's a docu docu-comedy in the
vein of modern family
um
the office uh parks and rec and uh what
is really exciting about it it's based
on a british show called this country
but it's also filled with people you
haven't seen before and i think it's
really nice to watch a show where you
get to discover a bunch of new amazing
comedians because we sort of see the
same faces over and over again and this
is like
new talent and the next generation of
brilliant people who you're going to
watch for years i also just like trust
paul feig so much he's made some of the
great comedies and
he knows how to balance heart and humor
and to me when you have the potent
combination of those two things it's
everything yeah we all need a laugh
right now
um
is it true that you stole something from
welcome to fletch
well i i wouldn't call it stealing it
was um uh
so i eat a lot of pb j
um
you mean something a little like this
ohio yes
um
i often get them as snacks on set and so
one day um the director of photography
was walking by and she had a pb j in her
hand and i went oh that that's for me
because they tend to give me pb and j's
to keep my blood sugar up and i grabbed
it out of her hand and took it and ate
it and then looked around and realized
that suddenly everyone had pb and j's
and that i had just you didn't need to
steal hers no that was her pb j that i
took right out of her hand and what i
realized was because she didn't say
anything i must be scary enough that she
thought i was that person that would
just take something out of her hand or
maybe you're an odd occurrence
so will you play a little game with me
yeah
all right it's q and a with pb and j
all right
i'm gonna eat one too all right which
celebrity take a big bite okay
which celebrity um would be your hall
pass and why
oh um whoa
oh
i wish i would think for george costanza
from seinfeld
you know george's quest to have sex and
eat a sandwich at the same time is like
my favorite episode call me
we're pulling a costanza right now
all right a tv show that you recommend
for us to binge what are you watching
what you into love island uk
what's your favorite ig account
i really love the dodo i love the dodo
no i wanna if i'm on instagram it's
because i'm watching dog videos okay no
have you ever woken up somewhere
and you didn't know what happened i have
something called vasovagal syncope
what is that
that makes me black out
like without drinking without drinking
like if i hit my elbow in a certain way
like i've fallen off a chair
so i was on a stilt walk
we were still walking through the forest
and i fell off the stilts so i woke up
in the middle of the forest with stilts
on my my feet i was not expecting this
answer at all
i mean i blacked out but i did it to
myself if you know what i mean
well
i have to tell you i'll cash i've had so
much fun
with you today
and um i totally celebrate you and i'm
so glad that you came here today thank
you thank you
and thank you for lunch
okay
the girl from plainsville is now
streaming on hulu and welcome to flash
airs thursday at 9 30 eastern on fox
they're both incredible thank you for
everything you're putting out into the
world
[Music]